[Music]
on this friday night a long-awaited wish
for indigenous people finally becomes a
reality a turning point in the historic
visit to the vatican
i am very sorry the emotional reaction
i'm happy and new expectations
the emergency to get people out of
mariupol
while rockets rained down on a russian
oil depot
key of recovering and rebounding we see
now so many cars plus the canadian
lawyer trading legal briefs for
ukraine's battle lines
and growing attraction i know in a weird
way that's
absolutely what happened the rising
popularity of indigenous culture tourism
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight colleen christie
good evening thanks for joining us
indigenous delegates who arrived in rome
earlier this week for historic meetings
at the vatican got what others have
worked decades to achieve an apology
from the pope for the abuses many
suffered in canada's residential school
system at the hands of the roman
catholic church
i ask for god's forgiveness and i want
to say to you with all my heart i am
very sorry
and i join my brothers the canadian
bishops in asking your pardon
the apology that we received today is
absolutely historic and so meaningful to
so many people but we've all been very
clear that there's so many
so many steps that we still have to take
and those next steps could come here in
canada as pope francis also committed to
visiting indigenous families in their
homeland possibly in july with more on
what was said in rome and reaction to
the pope's historic words let's bring in
our europe bureau chief crystal gomezing
for more crystal
calling indigenous delegates were in
tears when pope francis apologized but
he went further than that acknowledging
the broken family bonds along with the
cultural loss and identity
[Applause]
steps away from pope francis a fancy
dance performed with enthusiasm and
pride
not too long ago this was an
unacceptable display of culture to be
unlearned at residential schools
often at any cost
i am very sorry
i had tears
today when i heard those words
because like i said i hoped for it
i prayed for these quotes
for it let me give you
never expected to
live and see and feel it
to happen on my birthday
holy father
may the creator of the great spirit
bless us today the pope says he was
enriched by his encounters with the
inuit metis and first nations delegates
i also feel shame i'm saying it now and
i'm repeating it sorrow and shame
for the role that a number of catholics
particularly those with educational
responsibilities i didn't
think i would hear him say
how he felt
shame for
and guilt for
what the church did to our people the
pope's words today were historic to be
sure
they were necessary
and i appreciate them deeply
and i now look forward to the pope's
visit to canada
where he can offer those sincere words
of apology directly to our survivors and
their families we at itk look forward to
working with the canadian council of
bishops
and the vatican
to not only plan for this message to be
brought to canada
and to our people in our homelands
just like the dedication showed by metis
fiddler alexander custer rock the next
steps will require hard work chief
wilton little child used the term reckon
silly action his fellow delegates agree
the moment
is like when you're going out there
in the snow
and you see fresh moose tracks
that's the feeling that i have
because there's a possibility
the pope presented one member from the
inuit metis and first nations
delegations with a bronzed olive branch
a hopeful sign of peace and
reconciliation going into the future as
for other survivors of residential
schools they will get an apology from
pope francis in canada potentially
sometime in july colleen crystal
gomezing in rome crystal thank you
and as crystal mentioned the pope's
apology included recognition today of
the broken family bonds and major loss
of culture caused by the church here's
more of what the pope had to say
great harm was done to your identity and
your culture
many
to impose a uniformity based on the
notion that progress occurs
through ideological colonization
his words were a surprise to many but
they come after a long grueling battle
from those who've been searching for
accountability for decades eric sorenson
looks at reaction here at home and the
hope for what's to come
it took so long to get to this point the
shame the sorrow the clear admission of
wrongdoing by the catholic church
pope benedict and all the popes before
him refused to apologize until pope
francis did the commission
it was the courage of survivors of abuse
and their families that would not let
decades of mistreatment just fade away
i'm happy that you know finally
the pope has apologized
evelyn corkmas was a child at st anne's
residential school in ontario she only
wishes the apology had come sooner for
relatives who've passed away it's a very
heavy burden
of shame for a survivor to carry the
truth and reconciliation commission the
inquiry into murdered and missing
indigenous women and recently the
discovery of unmarked graves almost
certainly children who attended
residential schools have not only shaken
canadians but brought harsh
international scrutiny to the canadian
government and the catholic church the
world is watching this story unfold
here in rome successive prime ministers
have apologized we
are sorry and justin trudeau now
welcomes the church's contrition today's
apology is a step forward in
acknowledging the truth of our past in
order to right historical wrongs
but there's still work to be done indeed
indigenous leaders say the warmth we saw
in rome is tempered by the cold reality
that crimes were committed starting with
the european doctrine that justified the
taking of indigenous lands centuries ago
the people that have done these crimes
have to be accountable
and also the system
that set it up
have to be accountable next steps
include the expectation of millions of
dollars in compensation a return of
lands acquired by the church and a full
investigation of abuse that includes
access to the vatican archives what took
place in residential schools murray
sinclair who chaired the truth and
reconciliation commission says it's
important for action to be taken but the
apology is also a gesture of historic
consequence appropriations very
important to survivors it's an important
day for them to be able to hear
that what they have been saying all
along has validity and that
they are being believed
for many an uplifting moment in an
arduous reckoning for indigenous people
and all canadians that is far from over
eric sorensen global news toronto
a 24-hour crisis line is available to
support residential school survivors
it's toll free and you can speak in
confidence the number is 1-800-721-0066
turning to ukraine peace talks with
russia have resumed but neither side is
making it easy russia is accusing
ukraine of attacking an oil depot within
its borders and a convoy of red cross
vehicles trying to get stranded
civilians out of the besieged city of
mariupol has again been denied entry as
redmond shannon reports hopes of any
firm cease-fire are fading
a barrage of rockets hitting an oil
depot in bellagrad russia not far from
the ukrainian border followed by two
helicopters russia claims ukraine is to
blame for what would be a first attack
of this war on russian soil they just
reflect the real attention intention of
the ukrainian side and the real
intention for any peace talk initially
ukraine did not deny involvement i can
neither
confirm nor reject the the claim that
ukraine was involved in this later a key
security officials said it wasn't them
whoever is to blame it won't help
fragile peace talks which resumed online
on friday
in the south more bad news for the
people of besieged mariupol we are
currently on the move from zappoligi to
go to mario this red cross convoy was
forced to turn around as it tried to get
access to the city to escort a convoy of
evacuees to safety
time is running out for the people of
mario paul
they are desperately in need of
assistance we are running out of
adjectives to describe the horrors that
residents
in mariopol have suffered ukraine says
three thousand people still managed to
escape the city friday the red cross
says it will try again on saturday but
that russia won't allow them to bring
aid in
in kiev a visit from the european
parliament president
this is the whatever it takes moments
just after ukraine's leader vladimir
zelinsky shored up his own ranks firing
two generals labeling them traitors
the eu also courted china at a summit on
friday china should
if not support
at least not interfere with our
sanctions
as russia's foreign minister met with
his indian counterpart china and india
two asian powers who remain somewhat on
the fence in this widening global divide
redmond shannon global news london
on the outskirts of kiev thousands of
volunteers are working to defend the
city from russian forces so far they've
succeeded with russia claiming it's
scaling back military operations around
the capital that has allowed key
residents to return home jeff semple has
more on how they're trying to get life
back to normal
from the first moments of russia's
invasion ukraine's capital has found
itself in the crosshairs first day we
were hiding in nearest metro station i
was in panic when russia attacked kiev
in late february christina malnick and
her boyfriend fled her home city for the
relative safety of levive in western
ukraine
but they recently decided to return to
the capitol and were prepared for the
worst i remember i said to my boyfriend
that
if i'll die in next second that will be
okay because i'm in my home but instead
of death christine arrived to find her
city springing back to life
alive much more alive after weeks of
trying to claim the ukrainian capital
russia appears to be pulling back to an
extent refocusing some of its forces to
the east ukraine just recaptured this
suburb north of kiev and is rapidly
pressing forward
every day we are liberating more
villages and territories this ukrainian
commander told global news the situation
here is getting better but the battle
for keeve isn't over yet volunteers have
been digging these trenches by hand in
various locations right across the
capitol to help them fortify their
positions and push the russians back
this is keeve's last line of defense
a network of trenches carved through the
capital dug by members of ukraine's
territorial defense forces not soldiers
but civilians who volunteered to fight
including this ukrainian canadian
and then you realize that freedom isn't
free it comes at a cost dan bilac is
from toronto and moved to ukraine back
in the 90s the corporate lawyer is now
conducting night patrols on the
outskirts of kiev so ukraine's soldiers
can focus on the fight
he's one of more than one hundred
thousand ukrainian military volunteers
it showed how powerful
it can be to harness
the the enthusiasm of people and the and
the commitment and the resolution of
people
to defend their land
we're in fact winning this war because
of the fact that we have this kind of a
setup at least in central keeve the
sweet smell of victory is in the air
for the first time in a month this
high-end restaurant is serving customers
and its head chef is smiling i happy
because i feel like i'm at home as a
friday businesses are allowed to start
selling alcohol again ukrainians
toasting to a homecoming some thought
they'd never see i don't think anybody's
under any illusions that this is this is
done i think i think we've proven that
we can defeat these this enemy this city
is still within range of rockets and
artillery but many see this resumption
of some semblance of normal life as a
show of defiance
this coffee shop closed after russia's
invasion but just reopened and rebranded
kiev is now spelt with a y instead of
the traditional soviet spelling
because we are ukraine she says the war
rages on but they hope the battle for
the capital is nearly done
jeff semple global news keith
ukrainian mps on a mission in ottawa
coming up what they're asking canada to
provide to help fight russia plus water
works new funding to fix one of
iqaluit's biggest problems
prime minister justin trudeau has
announced funding to help fix iqaluit's
water system which has been contaminated
with fuel twice in the last six months
the federal government is setting aside
214 million dollars to build a new
reservoir and upgrade the city's
existing water supply system the work is
expected to be completed within four
years iqaluit's 8 000 residents were
unable to drink from the top for nearly
two months last year and spent six days
under a boil water advisory in january
five ukrainian mps are in ottawa pushing
for swift and concrete action to fight
the war against russia they sat down
with the prime minister and deputy prime
minister christie freeland to request
more financial and military support
we cannot do this with rifles
we have to have heavy weaponry to kick
russians
from our territory
because if we talk about the end of this
war we mean winning in this war
because other than that putin will not
stop
the mps are requesting canadian tanks or
funds to buy them elsewhere they'd also
like to see more sanctions
standing their ground still ahead
ukrainian civilians taking up arms
against russia's invasion
[Music]
ukraine has surprised the world with its
ability to push back against the russian
invasion its people fighting the war on
every front well earlier we told you
about the civilian defense force this
week for the new reality christa hesse
gives us a rare inside look at keeve's
territorial defense a force made up
almost entirely of untrained civilians
doing whatever it takes to protect their
homeland
huddled inside a bomb shelter in kiev
dozens of volunteers prepare molotov
cocktails
[Music]
they stuff pieces of styrofoam into
bottles which will act as a thickening
agent when mixed with gasoline it makes
these diy weapons all the more deadly
but the effort to defend ukraine's
capital goes far beyond homemade bombs
i'm wearing
military protection it's very unusual
for me alexi hondrough is still getting
used to the gear
and the kalashnikov he's not just any
civilian he's a former ukrainian prime
minister the youngest ever to have the
job but these days he's a soldier he and
his team conduct aerial intelligence
from this secret location in kiev
we need to find an enemy to
control
the
movements
and
to make sure that we understand their
logic
to make sure that we understand their
tactic and strategy
our cameras got rare access to the
operations nerve center where they
monitor aerial activity and work to
outwit the russians
so far it appears to be working it's
been five weeks since the invasion and
russia has failed to capture any major
city
but relentless bombing has left many of
them in ruin so they can't
take control over kiev but they can
destroy
a huge part of it christa hessie global
news
and for more on krista's look inside
kiev's territorial defense force watch
the new reality tomorrow night at 8
right here on global
next the bc tourist experience that goes
a lot deeper than sightseeing and
souvenirs
indigenous tourism is becoming a big
draw card and an unexpected benefit
supporting truth and reconciliation by
educating people about canada's historic
rights and wrongs including the
residential school system's failures as
mike delay explains indigenous tourism
is providing opportunities to share and
reconnect with indigenous culture
there's no denying the beauty of the
clahus first nation north of vancouver
on any given day you can see grizzly
bears and whales in their own habitats
and that's a huge draw for tourists but
the indigenous team that runs the clahus
wilderness resort says their guests
expect more
it's traveling with intention they're
coming with the intention of of having
that connection with with the people
that live there
it's called indigenous culture tourism
an immersive experience which chris tate
says is more authentic what's odd is
that market research done by the
indigenous tourism association found
that canadians are visiting in part
because of the residential school
tragedies yeah i know in a weird way
that's
absolutely what happened um
and it's continuing to you know to
happen whether from guilt or support for
reconciliation indigenous tourism will
take the boost in business last year the
industry brought in only a third of
pre-pandemic revenues the tourism
association is asking the federal
government to bet on them in the next
budget so they can grow the experiential
market which in turn would create jobs
and help their communities thrive
we see culture
dying across the country for many
nations unfortunately the language is
being lost but when young people see
that this is an industry where you can
actually embrace the culture embrace the
language embrace your traditions your
regalia wearing the events the festivals
these are things we're saving
and they see inviting strangers to see
it firsthand as an opportunity we want
the world to come see how indigenous
values are so that they can hopefully
learn from that
provided of course that they can tell
the stories of how they came to be
themselves
mike turley global news toronto
and that is global national for this
friday i'm colleen christie the road to
reconciliation remains long for
residential school survivors and their
families but with the pope's apology
there's no question the journey for
canada's indigenous peoples has taken an
historic step forward
we leave you tonight with the power of
the very language and culture
residential schools aimed to destroy
indigenous songs speech and dance rang
through the vatican today for all the
world to see
thanks for watching
[Music]